okay so i like the fact that you just
came out and said
i'm nervous like i was nervous during
this like it was a lot for me so i i
wonder you know when you're tackling
these performances and you're trying to
get over those nerves and you're trying
to figure out what you're gonna do what
was it number one that made you so
nervous and what was it that calmed you
down
very good question so what made me
nervous was
elvis is so
loved and so iconic you feel you feel
responsibility playing any human that
has actually lived but with him it's
it's like
it's it's a weight like i never felt
before okay and there's a responsibility
to his family and also putting his story
into context like that was a big thing
there's so many misconceptions about him
there's so many ideas of him so i felt
such a responsibility to bring the
humanity
get a haircut buttercup
in that moment
i watched that skinny boy transform
into a superhero
[Applause]
i basically what one thing like you were
saying before the camera started rolling
the fact that i knew that he experienced
stage fright it relieved so much cause i
knew in those moments i'm feeling fear
but he was feeling fear right so it's
it's not something that you need to not
feel in order to do things that you
believe in you know right and uh and so
that was beautiful so i i mean and then
it was just like waking up every day at
three in the morning terrified getting
to work and i had two years of doing
nothing else that helped a lot so by the
time i got on set i i was pretty clear
about what i was doing there's a lot of
people saying a lot of things
but in the end you gotta listen to
yourself
i would be remiss internet if i didn't
say
yes we still hear it in your voice and
the internet's losing its mind because
of that do can you just not shake them
you just can't shake you know at this
point i keep asking people is this my
voice you know because it feels this
feels like my real it's one of those
things that certain things trigger it
yeah and other times as well it's it's
uh i don't know when you live with
something for two years and you do
nothing else i think you can't help but
it becomes a fiber of your being you
know i know that priscilla had gave the
stamp of approval to this project so
what was that like knowing that she
approves and then also what your
relationship have you gotten to grow a
relationship with her
yeah so i i met her before we started
filming and and uh
and then getting to see her after she'd
seen the film
it was so
moving to me
because she's also dealt with all the
misconceptions about elvis
since
you know the day she met him and um so
that
getting to see what this means to her
just
i was so nervous when she was going to
watch the film because she knows him
better than anybody and i just thought
oh is she gonna what's she gonna think
you know and so when i when i heard what
she what she felt about it it just was
beyond words i just felt so good the
hardest part of channeling him is it the
lip curl is it the hit like what what is
it and you know you got to show me like
yeah
listen i wish i could
do it
yeah i think there's so many things out
there that have become these caricatures
and so even talking about him curling
his lip it's something he didn't do as
much as we think he did right or he'd do
it for a photo or he'd do it for so so
uh and and when he and so he was finding
how subtle could you go with things
and still have the essence and so it was
it was this constant back and forth
that's the tricky thing is going back
and forth between incredibly technical
things
and then
never losing the humanity like that was
that was the goal was always have his
soul in there you know so the moves
weren't
so what you're telling me is you already
had the moves
i had to work hard for those okay yeah
but the thing with him is they weren't
movers they were coming out of the
feeling of the music so for me it had to
be about finding the feeling of the
music moving me in that way and that
that's what was really fun it was
liberating now you know when people hear
you in this movie the first thing people
are going to say too is did you did you
think like where have you been all of
our lives sounding like that
[Music]
yeah i mean the whole beginning process
of this was was me kind of going do i
believe i can do it okay because i i
didn't believe it in the beginning but i
wanted to i wanted to take on the
challenge so it was like looking at
mount everest and going i want to climb
that but i don't know if i have it in i
need to get the base camp one first base
camp take it one step at a time yeah
yeah i like that so much you know um
just like elvis you're no stranger to
fame so
the way that people react to him is like
the girls lose their darn minds have you
had a fan encounter that you're like
whoa i can't believe that just happened
to me
i think every time i still have that
feeling of
shock when people know who i am
i just i just think of myself being a
little kid who you know nobody knew who
they were so i i really i feel you kind
of even now yeah i don't know if you get
used to it it really uh
i mean we had a moment on the plane
where i was like in a mask and a hat
right and the stewardess started playing
uh elvis songs and she said she said
this isn't tribute to you and i thought
i didn't even know that you you know the
fact that she knew that so that was
really special that's really really cool
and also just getting to hear his music
all the time through those experiences i
was going to say when you think about
his music i mean can you pick a favorite
especially now that you've embodied him
for
so long yeah because it's like moods you
know there's a different song that hits
you at a different point that's the
thing about this room that's so special
yeah is i mean
each one of these represents a different
country we have nearly every country in
the world represented here
elvis is the first
artist to sell over a billion records
like one year was what 25 million four
years he sold 50 million records
and then the next year then he sells 25
million
i mean he's a young kid at that point so
um and he's recorded so many songs he
he still holds the the record as as the
artist that has the most top 40 hits you
have this fear
of tackling elvis which we get and then
your mano imano with one of the greatest
actors
of all time you know what i'm saying in
tom hanks what are those moments like is
it a master class watching him work and
being with him or are there nerves you
know knowing you're you're in a scene
one-on-one with him for an extended
period of time yeah there definitely are
i
i didn't know what it was going to be
like when i first met him because he's
been my hero for as long as i can
remember
and so when i first met him at baza's
house in australia and i see him from
far away he's back in the in the
backyard and i come walking up and he
goes my boy and he holds out his arms
and gives me the biggest bear hug that
was my first interaction and then baz
walked away and then and then tom just
started sharing his feelings of fear
around portraying these two men and then
i could say you're afraid i'm terrified
and then and then we were colleagues and
then we could talk about our
vulnerabilities and that was a gift that
he gave me you know what the universe
does for you seriously and he's as
advertised isn't he yeah he's everything
you imagine him to be you hear him laugh
down the hallway and you go that's woody
you know
that's why
i love that so much and i and i like
that really we're getting to see this
movie through
the lens of colonel parker in a lot of
ways and that complicated
toxic loving all of those things
relationship that these two had i knew a
little bit about it but i didn't know a
lot about their history i knew that
there were issues so it's really
interesting to see how this movie dives
deep into that and also to acknowledge
you know you were talking about
misconceptions of elvis because i think
for a lot of like african americans we
have a bit of a complicated relationship
with elvis and his music you love the
music you appreciate the talent but also
knowing where a lot of the roots came
from i like that the movie went into
those things and really kind of told
that story you can't tell a story
without that right
you don't have elvis without black music
and culture
going down a beale street and you know
being in gospel churches and that's
that's what
it was sewn into the fiber of his being
from such a young age
that it was it was this pure love and i
think you gotta
it's i'm so glad that we get to tell
this story
in the truthful way you know and so yeah
i'm excited you saw that you know you're
about to skyrocket so i hope you have
people you can hold on tight to through
this process
he's holding all right
[Music]
you